past five months you have been waiting
for things to go back to the way things
were green arrow cannot be stopped
unless we all work together Ollie can
take care of himself
hey youtubers is Charlie new arrow
trailer we see the Black Canary statue
I'll try to explain what's going on with
her this season because she is coming on
all four of the shows but you know very
comic book II twist with everything so
the whole idea of this is just to let
you know that Oliver has been going at
solo in the three months since the last
season ended remember there's always
like a break between seasons that they
move in real time like what are the
characters been doing for the last three
months since team arrow went on a break
so we see Diggle who has officially gone
back into the army he's Rhian listed so
that's why he's not on Team arrow
Thea looks like she's working with
Oliver in the mayor's office
Felicity is supposed to be the only one
who's still in the arrow cave actively
helping out but you do see it like mr.
terrific and then Artemis come along
later to join the team you see mr.
terrific doing the comedy salmon ladders
so you know that new characters will be
joining the team like we've already seen
the last trailer I think I mentioned so
artemis the wild dog character and mr.
terrific are officially swapping in for
the team arrow characters that left the
team at the end of last season so we're
talking Diggle we're talking Thea we're
talking Laurel because she died we see
the statue of Laurel kind of
memorializing her as Black Canary but
expect all kinds of awkward Laurel jokes
whenever she learns that they made a
statue of her but the Laurel stuff is
like a completely different thing that
gets way more complicated so just to
talk about the stuff that's in this
trailer there's a little bit of comedy
with Oliver looking like he gets
captured as mayor Oliver Queen like Chad
Coleman Tyrese I'm gonna call him Tyrese
for now but that's not his name on the
show it's just that most the people
watching this will know him from walking
dead so he's like a gang leader that's
trying to consolidate power and he's
basically telling all of his underlings
that they need to work together to take
the green arrow down but separately it
looks like another gang is trying to
capture the mayor to try and use him in
some plot others like they don't know
that he's the green arrow
so Thea has that joke line where she's
like Oh Oliver can take care of himself
and you see this police officer looking
like he's trying to punch him out it's
very reminiscent of season 1 where
Malcolm Merlyn had all of her strung up
so when season 5 drops just be looking
for a lot of internal Easter eggs for
stuff and moments that happen during
season 1 because part of the big deal
this season is that there
trying to get back to the basics like
the core of the show is that it's all
about Oliver Queen in a very Christopher
Nolan Dark Knight esque universe him
trying to make the city better
he's recommitted to his cause and it
sounds like he's been savages hell which
is also very season one thing season one
was when he was dropping bodies
obviously it looks like he's not killing
people now but he has that anger inside
of him because of what happened to
Laurel so he's just raining fire on all
the bad guys of the city in the new
twist now is his time is Oliver Queen
like what is he going to be doing during
the day as mayor Oliver Queen we know
all about what's going on at night is
green arrow he's going to be training
the new team arrow
he'll learn about some of the other big
threats that are rising up now this kind
of looks like Ragman this person in the
mask here it's a twist on the Green
Arrow costume but I actually think that
this is the Prometheus villain and he's
wearing these is a way to mock the Green
Arrow remember the TV show version of
Prometheus who's going to be like the
big bad this season is going to be
someone who became Prometheus took the
mantle because his parents who were
criminals were killed by the green arrow
but even if your parents were terrible
wouldn't you seek revenge for their
murder so that's kind of where
Prometheus is coming from but we'll
probably just get a teaser for him in
the first couple of episodes it's the
same thing on the flash with savat are
like you see him in the trailer all
huddled over with his speed cult so if
you've read the comics you have like a
vague idea of where the character comes
from just like you know kind of where
Prometheus comes from seeking revenge
for his parents murder even though his
parents were terrible people so there is
a lot of comic-book stuff happening and
I don't think we see any Russia
flashbacks in this trailer but Dolph
Lundgren is gonna be the big bad of the
flashbacks he'll be like this big figure
in the Russian Bratva it's gonna be you
know like Oliver has those Bratva
tattoos I even think that we learned in
a previous season that he holds the rank
of captain inside the Bratva which is
hardcore so this will probably be the
story of that you'll learn how Oliver
gets that brought but tattoo but for
those of you asking when Laurel is
coming back Black Canary coming back
because Katie Cassidy signed a serious
contract to be a regular on all four TV
shows
meaning that she's probably gonna be on
Supergirl arrow legends of tomorrow in
the flash so I think that her
day lauryl on arrow will stay dead but
we might see Black Canary Laurel show up
on Supergirl like the version of Laurel
on that earth might still be alive so we
have black siren on the flash I'm
expecting black siren to come back so
just expect some big comic book II
twists when Laurel comes back but let me
know in the comments which character are
you guys most excited for this season on
arrow I'm actually I'm really excited to
see what they do with the Artemis
character I wonder if she might be like
a more balanced version of Thea because
I think they tried to make Thea really
savage but they never quite nailed it
with the blood lust it was just it was a
little too wonky so I feel like the
Artemis character might be a course
correction for that because just the
setup for her character the way they
explained her last season which is way
more badass from baseline than Thea was
but over in the Iraqi training montage
flashbacks I'm not sure when Dolph
Lundgren is gonna show up he might not
be in the first couple of episodes but
I'm sure he'll be along pretty soon so
get height they still have a ways to go
before they start filming the four night
crossover that's going to be Episode
eight of all the shows this year but
usually about the time the season
premieres that's when they're getting
ready to film it so we'll start seeing
some stuff for that pretty soon and I am
expecting a Supergirl Superman trailer
to drop really soon too but they didn't
start filming that show till a little
bit after arrow and flash started
filming this year so they're a little
bit behind what I'm gonna do tonight
though is post a thor odin's a picture
of homeless Odin on set so we have a
pretty good idea of what Loki did with
him at the end of Thor the dark world so
crazy DC Marvel stuff happening this
weekend what you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for the flash
trailer I just posted you can click here
to learn all about the Justice League
dark movie what's going on with
Constantine in the animated movie thank
you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight